a manhunt is intensifying in Kansas for
one of two suspects in a deadly shooting
at a crowded bar
police say you go via Nueva morales is
armed and dangerous they announced the
arrest of the other suspect javier
Alatorre a overnight they're accused of
killing four people and wounding five
others early Sunday morning our lead
national correspondent David Begg know
is outside the bar in Kansas City Kansas
David you spoke with one of the injured
we did in fact he still got a bullet
Anthony lodged in a muscle in his back
the candles behind me are at the back
door to the bar and there is a sign you
can clearly see security cameras in use
and those security cameras are what
helped police identify the suspects here
America's latest mass shooting happened
in a heavily populated Hispanic
neighborhood here in Kansas City Kansas
we're told the bars a hole in the wall
there were only about 40 people inside
and the man you're about to hear from
says one of the gunmen walked in he
started shooting and simply sprayed the
room as he fired when it hit me felt
like I got hit by damn bus
Michael Barajas was among the five
people injured a bullet is still lodged
in his shoulder police say two gunmen
started shooting inside the tequila
Casey bar just a half hour before
closing time Sunday morning killing four
men what happened man I was there with
my cousin we just we stand in there
playing pool i standing up against the
wall and man I just heard about like
four shots when I turned over to the
right I just seen seen an arm swing up
and seen the flash and I seen it
pointing straight at me and I tried to
kind of turn but there was no you know
get another way it hit me he didn't know
going in going into my back hitting my
my shoulder blade and fracturing my
shoulder blade police say the first
suspect that you see here got into an
argument earlier that evening the
bartender had told him to leave right
then and there he picked up a cup that
was right there that man that man
returned hours later with an accomplice
both were armed with handguns police
identified the suspects overnight as
hugo via and Wavell morales and javier
Alatorre a he just walked on
that's where we was looking for and then
just I was sure there was a vigil for
the victims Sunday evening emotions were
raw one of the guys but raha says the
small bar was packed there were about 40
people inside how would you describe
what it was like to go through what you
went through horrifying the screams
afterwards just their bone-chilling
seeing bodies drop and you know
something usually watching a movie
you're seeing in real life the four
people who were killed are all Hispanic
no names have been released as of this
morning two of the deceased are Mexican
nationals
you know Gail there is a security guard
on duty at the bar every Saturday night
but last Saturday he didn't show up
wonder if that would have made a
difference thank you very much David